réseau ou tu es tu crois que frizot il
est tombé sur lui
danger griffes pointues j'espère bien
que non olalala la frise au réseau
freedom rides ou une prise au réseau hi
lo un si petit mouton dans ce monde si
grand potentiel chez une aiguille dans
une botte de foin
j'ai bien peur qu'on s'y perd de nous
mêmes c'est un légume jolie chanson pray
qui donne du courage pour de bon
et
c'est drôlement beau ce qu'ils ont
travaillé dur puisqu'il chante
tiens dont des amis se joue offerts dans
les grains
un nouveau ce est chantée masse ou ténor
chante quelque chose pour voir ce que tu
voudras je connais une jolie chanson qui
donne du courage pour deux bombes qui
ont de leur côté par la peur s'envole a
dit c'est quoi une jolie chanson géniale
l'écho non c'est pas les cons c'est
freezout y six mois